[Music]
as a factual matter there's not much
question that the obama administration
spied on the donald trump for president
campaign a government informant on the
government payroll
approached at least three members of the
trump campaign secretly gathered
information from them and secretly
passed it back to government handlers in
the obama administration
you can claim all of that was justified
you can't claim
it wasn't spying because it was spying
yet democrats are continuing to insult
your intelligence by
pretending that it wasn't somehow here
was congressman eric swellwell on this
program
just last night tell me why
spying on the trump campaign was not
spying just speak slowly so i could
understand
it was not spying what they're doing so
what was it they were conducting a
criminal investigation
but it's not just democrats who are
lying about this
obedient servants of the national
security state from both parties are
participating in this cover-up
the media mindless and lemming-like as
always
is of course dutifully backing them up
here's a brief selection
i am even more convinced that the fbi
did exactly what my fellow citizens
would want them to do
when they got the information they got
and that it has nothing to do with
donald trump there's no evidence that
there was a spy put into this
trump campaign all the other people
who've seen the intelligence in your own
party are saying it there's just
no there there i'm wondering what it
will take for you congressman zelda to
say he's full of it
[Music]
so let's try this again in the service
of clear language richard painter is
professor at the university of minnesota
he worked as an ethics lawyer in the
bush administration he's now seeking the
democratic
nomination for senate in the state of
minnesota richard painter joins us now
richard thanks
for coming on thank you
so um we know that an fbi and cia
informant on the government payroll
making quite a bit of money from the
government
made contact with at least three members
of the trump campaign
during the campaign gathered information
from them surreptitiously and passed it
back
to the obama administration now you can
argue that was justified and i'm
open-minded
but that's spying tell me why it's not
spying
the speaker of the house of
representatives has already talked about
this paul ryan
representative gowdy richard burr over
in the united states senate intelligence
committee
uh republicans and democrats because
they
they have seen the relevant information
including a lot of them have seen the
classified information which i have not
seen and neither has fox news
seeing the classified information and i
don't know if this is the news channel
of the fiction channel but we need to
focus on the facts here okay
wait hold on so slow down if you would
please stop with the invective
and explain to me again slowly why given
the facts set that i just presented to
you
and i think we can agree that that's
true that that's not spying
no i don't think we can what
circumstances would that knock your
spine
well the speaker of the united states
house of representatives has looked at
the facts and richard burr over in the
senate
uh and the intelligence committee has
looked at the facts including the
classified information which i have not
seen in fact so what do you think hold
on okay
you've already said that you've already
said that hold on i i understand you're
repeating yourself
and you've just confirmed that whatever
republican leaders say you believe so
it's a little odd you're running as a
democrat
another conversation but suggest to me
what
they might know hold on suggest to me
what they might know just speculate if
you would just go crazy as a former law
professor
what they might have seen that would
lead them to believe the facts that i
just
laid out that are not contested do not
amount to spying
not whether they're justified or not but
why is that not spying
any republican who saw a shred of
evidence that the obama administration
was spying on the trump campaign would
clearly have said it was sparring yet
the speaker the united states hold on
i'm asking you as an officer someone
running for office use your brain
tell me why given what i just said i'm
gonna ask you for the third time it's
really simple i'm not asking whether it
was justified or not it may have been
but why is that not spying secretly
gathering information on somebody and
passing it back to your handlers
in the administration is spying but you
won't concede it is because trey gowdy
says it's not
but you're a democrat i i'm totally
confused by this conversation
it doesn't matter whether you're a
democrat or republican the fbi and why
don't you keep studying republicans
it has nothing to do with the fbi has a
job to do it the russians are trying to
destabilize our country as they have
tried to destabilize western democracies
for a hundred years
uh our fbi has an obligation to find out
who
is interfacing with the russians and to
get the advisor warrants from a judge
and make sure and follow those people we
are not going to was there was there
was there in the united states i get it
was there a fisa warrant in this
specific case because
the first contact between the fbi and
cia informant and
a member of the trump campaign took
place in july of 2016.
that was three weeks before the
counterintelligence investigation
started
so are you saying do you have
information there was a fisa warrant for
that
no i'm not saying that there is no
evidence what are you saying
i acted inappropriately the members of
the united states
senate and house who have looked at the
classified information which i have not
seen
have concluded that the fbi acted upon
well you could continue to make up
stories about spy gate by the way i'm
not making up any
sweet slow down slow down and stop with
the insults i'm not making up stories
i'm stated no i'm stating known facts
which you are not contradicting nobody
is contradicting we know this to be true
unless
we're wrong in which case tell me how
i'm wrong but you haven't
and i'm asking you given that that
happened
why are we sure that that was justified
if it took place
before the counterintelligence
investigation opened
you suggested it was a fisa warrant that
made that legal
do you have knowledge of that are you
just making that up no
i am saying that members of the house
and senate who have looked at the
classified information which i have not
seen
democrats and republicans have concluded
that the fbi acted appropriately
encountering a foreign intelligence
operation inside the united states
aimed at destabilizing our country and
i'm saying i would like to know
more and and you're attacking me for
wanting to know more would you like to
know
for example who authorized this on what
legal basis did this take place are
these
interesting questions to you or do you
think it's unpatriotic to ask them
because that's
that's a suggestion i want to ask
questions i want to know why
i want to know why the fbi didn't
uncover what the trump campaign was
doing in 2016 including the trump tariff
meeting
and blow the cover on that so we would
have known about that before the
election
we should have known about that the fbi
did not disclose what they knew
about the russians and the trump
campaign colluding
we should have been told and that's just
wrong and the fbi
i don't even understand what you're
saying i haven't understood a single
article
okay unfortunately basically good luck
with your senator
i hope voters can understand what you're
saying because i can't nice to see you
andrew mccarthy is an assistant former
assistant u.s attorney for the southern
district of new york and he joins us
tonight andy thanks a lot for coming on
my pleasure so the semantic smokescreen
tiresome i think it is a semantic
smokescreen if you just agree please
tell me
but the deeper question is what was the
legal basis for this what was the
authorization you just heard richard
painter suggest there was a fisa warrant
for this
is that true could it be true you're
quite right
tucker it is a semantic difference i
mean even uh
chairman gowdy who objected to the word
spy admits there was an informant right
so
on one side of this we have people who
are engaged in hyperbole
the other side they're engaged in
euphemism but we're talking about the
same thing we're talking about
a covert operative who was sent in to
get information
you don't have to have a fisa
surveillance warrant to use
an informant in fact it's a it's a
pretty low standard
uh we know there was some fisa
surveillance there may have been more
than we know about
but that began in october and it went uh
basically for most of the next year well
into the trump campaign
they were using an informant or a spy
whatever you want to call it
at least one at least beginning in july
and i think the issue here is
why they were doing it not what you call
it and
the most objectionable thing i i think i
heard from
your last guest is he kept saying the
people who've looked at the classified
information
uh in point of fact they haven't seen
the classified information a big part of
what this whole debate has been about
has been the fact that they've been
asking for months and months
from the justice department and the fbi
to see the classified information
and they've been stonewalled yeah i mean
that conversation honestly was demented
i'm still confused by it
but but the core questions remain um
and tell me if i got the timeline wrong
apparently the conversations between
this informant and members the trump
campaign began before
the counter-intelligence investigation
into trump campaign ties to russia began
so on what basis was this authorized
well the investigation is formally
opened
we think around july the 31st now
they are allowed to do preliminary steps
before they open a full throttle
investigation and presumably they used
that authorization or that authority
that they have
to to use informants but you know we're
speculating and we shouldn't be
speculating at this point we should
actually know the answers we should be
now
at this point able to say exactly when
this investigation
open not on paper but when it really
opened when they started to do
stuff when they started to monitor
people uh that's what we need just in
one sentence because we're out of time
but just fact check it for me
you'd need a pretty high bar to do this
in administration to a rival campaign
right
you sure should you sure should yeah you
sure should that's my instinct
in mccarthy thank you thanks tucker